Hi there.
I've had a lot of people ask me how I wash my hair in space...
...and I thought I'd show you how I do it.
What I like to do is start by just putting some hot water,...
...squirting it onto my scalp.
And I have a mirror here so I can kinda watch what I'm doing.
Sometimes the water gets away from you,...
...and you try and catch as much as you can.
Then I just work the water up through to the ends of my hair.
Then I take my no rinse shampoo and squirt it also on the scalp...
...just a little bit.
And rub it in.
There, I think that's pretty good.
And now as my hair dries, as the water evaporates from my hair,...
...it will become humidity in the air...
...and then our air conditioning system will collect that into condensate.
And it won't be long and our water processing system...
...will turn that into drinking water.